le chef de l'État a dit ce matin cette
réforme est indispensable et vitale
élément de langage qui ont été repris
par le porte-parole du gouvernement
Olivier Véran vous êtes vous êtes
d'accord avec cette dramatisation entre
guillemets bon il y a pas de
dramatisation il y a un enjeu qui est
partagé vous savez j'entends dire par
Monsieur que nous avons été sourds dans
on n'a pas été sourd nous par exemple le
groupe modèle et par l'intermédiaire de
François Bayrou on a demandé plus de
temps pour dialoguer on l'a eu et ce
dialogue il a il a eu lieu
encore lundi il y avait des négociations
à la veille de la présentation et nous
lundi par exemple on rencontrait la CFDT
et la CFDT admettait que ce temps qui
avait été supplémentaire était un temps
qui avait été positif et sur lequel
comme viennent de le dire ma collègue on
a fait des avancées on a fait des
avancées sur les petites retraites on a
fait des avancées sur la pénibilité on a
fait des avancées sur les carrières
longues et je crois qu'on a une réforme
qui est une réforme équilibrée moi je je
respecte parfaitement l'attitude des
syndicats ils sont dans leur rôle mais
sur le terrain moi les Français que je
vois sur masse circonscription on a
commencé la séquence de voeux on voit
beaucoup de monde en ce moment les gens
ont la conscience que une réforme est
nécessaire ils sont pas gênée par l'idée
de devoir travailler ensemble c'est ce
qui vous disent alors ils sont ils
savent que il faut faire une réforme
mais tout le monde évidemment moi le
premier on se dit c'est préférerais ne
pas travailler plus préférerais
évidemment mais on sait que pour la
financer pour des droits sociaux
nouveaux il faut un peu plus d'activités
et d'ailleurs vous avez même des
syndicats qui parlent de ce cette
activité supplémentaire après certains
blocs sur le seuil d'âge d'autres voilà
mais vous savez juste pour conclure vous
parlez de la logements de de des
cotisations un logement des cotisations
il était prévu il était prévu on
accélère simplement de cinq ans
et je vois j'ai surtout vu votre vos
propositions vos propositions c'est 60
et 40 à nuités bon moi je j'ai une
question à vous poser 60 ans 40 à nuités
comment vous financez sans baisser les
sans baisser sans baisser les pensions
actuelles je vous pose juste cette
question et après moi je suis je suis
prêt disposé à faire ce qu'on a fait
avec les autres travailler et le travail
qui a été mené pendant toute cette
séquence oui mais je finis le travail
qui a été mené sur toute cette séquence
c'est d'avoir un régime équilibré pour
pas revenir dessus dans un an dans deux
ans régime équilibré et une volonté
forte de la majorité et d'un certain
nombre de courants progressistes d'avoir
des nouvelles avancées sociales et moi
je suis désolé la retraite à taux plein
à 1200 euros pour ceux qui ont travaillé
la retraite minimum pardon à 1200 euros
c'est une avancée ce que disait monsieur
c'est que c'était prévu dans la loi de
2003 et vous auriez pu le faire
et on le fait on le finance et on
finance aussi on finance aussi un
certain nombre de mesures sur les
carrières hachées un certain nombre de
mesures et ça nous l'a été encore redit
aujourd'hui et et là-dessus les
syndicats vous êtes en phase sur la
question de la pénibilité la prise en
compte de la pénibilité on avance sur
ces sujets là le meilleur partage de la
valeur ajoutée il y a un débat au sein
de la majorité sur l'augmentation quand
même des cotisations patronales le
modèle est favorable François beroux l'a
dit ce matin il a déclaré que le projet
de réforme présenté hier était
améliorable est-ce que c'est de ce point
de vue là est-ce que vous allez faire
pression lors des débats est-ce que vous
avez déposé des amendements est-ce que
vous allez faire la pression sur
Renaissance monsieur Balanant pour
cueillez les amendements qui prévoit une
augmentation des cotisations patronales
déjà vous aurez noté qu'il y a un petit
bouger dans le texte par rapport à très
technique et pas lisible pour l'opinion
qui est très oui mais voilà mais après
on a cette on a cette interrogation
effectivement on n'a pas complètement
tranché de savoir si on déposera des
amendements ou pas on regarde et on
voulait analyser le texte définitif
avant de se fixer définitivement en tout
cas nous une chose est sûre et là
peut-être que Monsieur m'entendra c'est
nous on est pour que cette retraite
comme notre système comme notre société
soit juste et que effectivement ceux qui
pour des raisons X ou Y gagnent beaucoup
plus parfois soit parfois un peu plus
la répartition soit un peu plus un peu
mieux fait mais toujours avec cette idée
de préserver l'idée que l'activité il
faut aussi la soutenir c'était le sens
de notre amendement sur les super
dividendes qui permettait de revoir
lors de la discussion du budget qui a
été rejetée par le gouvernement alors
qu'il a été voté par une partie des
oppositions qui d'ailleurs ont pris un
témoin regardez pour affaiblir le
gouvernement devait vous alliez du MoDem
ils sont contre vous est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer que ça se passe de la même
façon dans cette discussion on a sur ce
déjà on a déjà énormément discuté et et
entre les différents courants de la
majorité le modem horizon Renaissance et
à l'intérieur de renaissance il y a
aussi des courants qui sont on pense pas
tous pareils chez nous et c'est très
bien on a beaucoup discuté et c'est ce
qui nous a permis d'avancer sur ce genre
de la détermination des opposants est-ce
que vous craignez avec cette journée
mobilisation et aussi cette contestation
qui va durer est-ce que vous craignez un
mouvement social de grande ampleur de
type gilet jaune par exemple déjà
les Français ils étaient en attente
maintenant leur a proposé le texte on
leur a présenté il y a certains
certaines craintes qui ont été levées il
y a des gens vous savez qui n'avaient
pas tout le monde n'avait pas compris
que ça allait être progressif
l'augmentation de la durée des
cotisations et pour certains qui
pensaient justement et vous les citiez
tout à l'heure partir en retraite la
prochainement il pensait peut-être
qu'ils allaient prendre trois ans de
plus non c'est pas ça le sens de la
retraite donc déjà il faut expliquer le
sens comment ça fonctionne et à nous
aussi d'expliquer un certain nombre de
mesures qui sont des mesures d'équilibre
et qui sont des mesures d'avancer social
je je on le redis et on va l'expliquer
on va montrer par exemple là on parle
des 1200 euros bah les 1200 euros
effectivement c'était dans la loi avant
ça n'a jamais été fait nous le faisons
c'est une avancée et elle est expliquée
à quelqu'un qui touche aujourd'hui 900
euro de retraite il va toucher à partir
de la promulgation du texte 1200
expliquez-lui que c'est pas une mesure
sociale je suis désolé sans études
ensuite on va avoir des mesures sur
l'accompagnement sur le C2P le C2P qui
permettra justement
laissez-moi finir le C2P qui permettra
justement un certain nombre de personnes
de faire des reconversions et donc avoir
été dans un métier difficile disant 15
ans ça peut être trop ça suffit et cette
personne grâce à ce qu'on est en train
de mettre en place pourra faire de la
reconversion plus facilement et ça je
suis désolé c'est une attente des
syndicats depuis un moment donc on n'est
pas dans le tout blanc tout noir sur ce
texte et je pense que notre
responsabilité maintenant c'est de
l'expliquer aux Français dans le temps
qui va venir et dans le temps du débat
parlementaire